Hello!
Welcome back, Master!
Oh, Master!
Welcome!
Oh, Minto.
Hello.
Hello, Minto.
Hello!
Hi, Mint!
Hi!
Sorry if I sound extra... nasally today.
I don't know, my... my... my... throat... no, my nose... is extra... extra nasally.
Actually, I have some cough drops.
Maybe I should take them.
Oh,
what nose?
Darn sinus.
I know!
Hope it's not Rona.
I don't think so.
Because...
I think it's just a cold.
I think I got a cold from overworking myself.
But also, I don't think it's Rona because... I haven't really been like... out.
I like... have kind of... the day... the day before I started feeling bad, I... all I did was take a walk outside.
But I walked for a long time, so...
Did you see Matoya?
Yeah!
We hung out last night!
Oh, again!
Sorry, I meant to say... I wanted to apologize for... for moving the time.
If you're watching the VOD of this, thank you!
But... if you are watching it live, thank you!
No, no!
Thanks for the perk!
WiseSage1 said, your oshi is the light of your life, so investing in them is just utility bills.
This goes towards your oshi.
Thank you!
Some extra holo coins to start with.
No, may not be transferable to Holocure.
Ken used his regular dollars and said, thank you!
Thanks for the super chat, you guys.
Yeah, so I'm sorry that I had to move the time.
I've... I've booked a little bit of some stuff.
And that's my fault.
So I'm really sorry about that.
But I didn't want to cancel the stream.
So I was like, I'll just push it a little bit.
But yeah, howdy, man.
Howdy!
I just cried for a maid yesterday.
I know!
Oh my gosh.
Yeah, it was like... yeah.
I was watching too.
And... um...
You know, I never was a super active watcher.
But she was one of the members I was subscribed to.
And... um...
You know, I really loved Aqua's performance.
Like, she was a true idol.
She is a true idol, you know.
So... um... I really was happy I could watch her graduation.
Um...
But when she played the one song...
I really like her one song.
Oh my gosh, I can't remember the full name.
The Desha one.
Um...
But...
What's it called?
My brain.
Sorry, I have a...
I have...
Sick brain.
Yes, yes, yes, yes, yes.
When that one played.
It's my favorite of her songs.
So I was like...
That was so...
It was so...
But yeah...
Um...
Anyway...
It's okay.
Because...
Um...
You know...
As...
As one says...
Don't take your Oshii for granted.
And...
Appreciate the time you have with your Oshii.
You know...
Just enjoy...
Idols.
Vtuber.
Just have fun with it.
You know?
And enjoy...
And have fun with the time...
That...
Uh...
We can all hang out and have fun together.
Yeah.
So...
You know...
I'm...
Uh...
I think it's grown more recently.
I used to say...
Like...
I'm no...
Um...
Uh...
What's the word?
Newbie?
I'm no newbie to graduation.
Since I've been into idols for...
Over a decade now.
So...
But...
I use...
And I used to say...
That maybe...
It wasn't as common in the Vtubes.
But...
I think more recently...
It's kind of grown...
A little bit more common...
To have...
More people...
Uh...
Graduating.
So...
Um...
But...
Uh...
You know...
And it doesn't...
For me...
It doesn't get easier.
But it...
Um...
You know...
Uh...
It does...
The more...
The more it happens...
The more I do...
Uh...
Tend to appreciate...
Um...
The people that I...
You know...
Support and follow...
That much more.
So...
Uh...
Yeah...
Hahaha...
Uh...
But...
Today...
We are...
Playing...
Holocure...
This is actually...
I know...
It's very strange...
For me...
To not have played this before...
But...
To my credit...
I...
Didn't...
Okay...
So...
I...
Wasn't sure...
If I would like...
Vampire Survivors...
You know?
And...
I was like...
I...
I thought...
That the...
That the gameplay...
Wasn't really my style...
Like I was just like...
Ah...
I don't...
I don't really know...
And then I got like...
Addicted to this one game...
It wasn't Vampire Survivors...
But it was like...
A mobile clone...
Basic...
Not a clone...
But you know...
Mobile style...
It was...
It's called like...
Survivor.io...
Or something...
You know?
And I...
I like...
Sunk my tooth into that...
I was like...
Wow...
My god...
Have fun with the game...
My main is Sui-chan...
But I hope you find a character...
That vibes with you...
Thank you...
Yeah...
And so...
And then I was just like...
Oh my gosh...
Wait...
This kind of...
Game is so fun...
And then by that point...
I was like...
Vampire...
The Vampire Survivors hype...
Had like...
Died down...
And I hadn't played it...
And then...
I was like...
Thinking the other day...
I was just like...
Oh man...
What can I have like...
On my schedule that...
Is...
Something that I can play...
Somewhat easily...
On my laptop...
Since I'm still in Japan...
And I was like...
Wait a second...
Um...
Holocure...
Is a thing...
And...
I've always...
I've been wanting to play it...
This whole time...
So...
Yeah...
We're here...
And I can play it...
And I can be like...
Hehe...
I know these people...
Hahaha...
Oh...
And of course...
My baby here...
Kiwawa...
So...
Um...
I will...
Of course...
Play as Kiwawa...
I will try as many people as I can...
And see how...
Each one plays...
And...
Um...
Uh...
Which...
Kind of...
Suits my style...
My vibe...
Best...
And...
Uh...
But...
You know...
If I'm not a Kiwawa man...
Kiwawa...
Don't...
Don't hate me...
Okay?
Hehe...
If I'm not a Kiwawa man...
I will change my style...
My play style...
To become Kiwawa man...
Hahaha...
I've been seeing a lot of people saying theirs...
You know...
Someone earlier said Sui-chan...
Um...
I saw...
Some...
Reine...
Um...
What else?
I'm seeing...
My...
Mumei...
Koronei...
Sana...
Iris...
What are you guys playing?
Fauna...
Mumei...
Iris...
Suisei...
Bales...
Ali...
Amei...
Gura...
Buibu...
Is she in?
The game?
Are the new girls in?
No...
Oh...
So you're just a liar...
Hahaha...
Haha...
Oh no...
I mean...
They're a secret beta tester...
Nevermind...
Sorry...
Hahaha...
I was gonna say...
I don't...
I don't think they're...
Hahaha...
Secret beta tester over here...
Oh...
Now we know...
The secret...
They're gonna be like...
Bibu is the next...
Um...
You know...
Bibu is the next...
Uh...
Um...
Meta...
Everybody...
Okay?
Hahaha...
They're a beater...
We got a beater in the chat...
Everybody...
I saw K...
Was in the pre-chat...
K...
If you're here...
K-U...
Full name...
I know how much you love being called K-U...
Hahaha...
K...
If you're here...
Shut the hell up...
Okay...
Hahaha...
Um...
Yeah...
I'm super excited to play...
So...
Mmm...
Hahaha...
K...
U...
It's like I'm your mom...
I'm calling you full name...
So that you...
Know you're in trouble...
K...
John...
U...
Hahaha...
I really caught him in stream...
Wow...
Thank you...
Hahaha...
Great to meet you...
At Otakutan...
At the beginning of the month...
Wow...
Thank you...
Hahaha...
Mami Minto...
No...
Hahaha...
What the full government name...
Cool...
So...
We're gonna play...
Obviously we only have Mith here...
Let's see...
Ame...
Shoots three projectiles forward...
Mid-range stab attack in front...
Tentacle...
Okay...
Let me explain also...
What kind of style I like...
Hiya Minto...
Guess who I main...
Okay...
You're Ame Oshii...
But...
I'm just gonna throw out...
Corona...
Hahaha...
Um...
So I kind of like...
Uh...
And if you watched my...
Um...
Maid of the Dead playthrough...
Maybe you...
Kind of see this...
When I...
Um...
Did that game...
Is like...
Uh...
I like a...
I like having a barrier...
That kind of melts people...
When they come in contact with me...
I like having...
Like something that spins around me...
So that when I walk...
It just kind of does the...
The work for me...
Hahaha...
So...
The BL book...
Okay...
I don't know...
So Sana main...
Okay...
Hahaha...
Um...
Also...
I know some people will probably have...
Many opinions...
On...
Who I should play...
Or what the meta is...
Or...
How to best enjoy the game...
In their opinion...
But...
Since this is my first time playing...
I'm just gonna take it easy...
I'm just gonna have a good time with it...
Let's just have a good time...
I don't mind backseating...
But try not to get too passionate about it...
Okay...
Hahaha...
So...
Yeah...
Just wanna throw that out there...
Keywawa!
Short range slash in front...
Okay...
Oh!
They also have different HP's and everything...
Swings and a half circle arc in the front!
Cali...
Awww...
Should I start with...
Keywawa sounds hard to start with though!
Short range slash in the front?
Heheh...
Sounds hard...
Kali's...
Feels...
I was gonna say Kali probably would be the quote-unquote easiest.
Also!
Oh!
I wanted to say!
The little sprite!
Kaitsu, thank you!
You guys see the sprite on my...
The one on my head is moving really fast.
And then the other one is kind of going slow.
So I just added both.
But look!
I'm basically like a little...
I'm in Holocure style!
So thank you!
Thank you Kaitsu for the...
You pumped this out so fast!
Thank you!
Trying to fall off my head?
She can try as she might but she's glued there.
You can't see because of my big head.
But Kali is like running so funny.
Okay!
Let's try Kali then.
Maybe?
No VTuber!
Why you no pick my mane?
Stage mode.
Endless mode.
Let's do stage mode first.
Okay, I'm playing on keyboard.
Is it Wasta?
Or is it...
It is Wasta?
Okay, okay.
I'm guessing Wasta and then I control direction with my mouse.
I'm guessing.
So...
Hollow Aqua.
Oh!
I want to play the Halloween castle!
Uh-uh.
Javits security contractor got seriously mad with people.
Oh well.
Yeah, I remember you saying that before.
But yeah, it was the last song.
So it's okay.
Okay.
Grassy plains it is.
Here I go.
Right click or left click to toggle.
Right stick to aim.
Wait.
Okay, okay.
So...
And then we collect these.
Oh my gosh.
Wait, wait, wait.
Yeah.
There we go.
Okay, okay.
Yeah.
Oh!
Okay.
Our first upgrade.
You should use controller.
Well, that's not possible because I am...
I am in Japan and I don't have a controller.
But thanks for your recommendation.
I think I...
I feel like I'm going to be saying that probably like 50 times this stream.
But...
You know.
Two.
Upgrade the scythe swing.
Increase damage.
Hold on.
Let me read everything first, you guys.
Stop it!
Let me read everything first!
Gain 1% crit buff every second up to 10% if taking damage by the target.
That's half the buff.
If eating food, plus 5% crit for 10 seconds.
Gain a shield that absorbs up to 15 damage.
Every 15 seconds, the shield refreshes.
Also reduces damage.
Oh, it's a body pillow, though.
Who needs to read?
Yeah.
No reading allowed, VTuber.
We're not reading.
You know what?
I'm going to play eeny, meeny, miny, moe.
Eeny, meeny, miny, moe.
Catch a tiger by his toe.
If he hollers, let him go.
My mom said to...
Pick the very best one.
And you are not it.
You guys got lucky.
What was it?
Oh, okay.
Wait, wait, wait.
So...
Hold on.
So it's...
Oh, okay.
I see how it is.
I see how it works.
Okay, okay.
I thought it was like click.
Oh, no!
The deadbeats!
I thought it was like click to...
Okay, I get it.
I get it.
Yeah, click and just leave it.
You auto attack.
Yes, yes, yes, yes.
Okay, got it.
Got it.
I like to have the control.
Do you guys feel that way too?
Do you guys feel that way?
It's automatic attacking.
Yeah, I thought like if I left clicked, it would attack.
Do like an additional.
But that makes sense.
Mm-hmm.
Okay.
Death.
When defeating a target with Scythe Swing or Death, there's a 20% chance to create an explosion?
Ooh.
Picky, picky, picky mine.
Targets within 100 pixels take 10% extra damage.
How much is 100 pixels?
Picky, picky, picky mine.
100 pixels.
Oh, it'll show you a circle.
Okay.
It'll show you on screen.
It was like people out here literally counting individual pixels.
Increase attack area by 15%.
Okay.
That's a lot.
Well, we already have this in our lineup.
Okay.
I see now.
We have one, two, three, four, five things.
Gain 15%.
Oh, sorry.
15 max HP for every six points of total max HP.
Increase damage.
So, people are saying that the P-Mine is good.
Picky, picky, picky mine.
Does the ghost sick?
Yeah, a little bit sick.
One or two.
I did say that I like to have like a little...
Well, it's 10% extra damage, but it's not like a barrier like I wanted.
What?
What do the stars and stuff mean?
These two have stars.
This one is obviously attack.
And then this one is a little t-shirt.
Just what kind of skill they are.
Stars are passive skills.
Okay.
Stars don't take up slots.
Oh, wait.
Actually?
Oh, I see it.
Okay.
Now I see it.
Oh, okay.
Item, weapon, skill, skill.
I see it.
I can read.
Let's try death.
Oh, my gosh.
Scared me.
There's so many guys here.
Go away.
I'm just trying to collect my stuff.
Why?
The deadbeats so powerful.
It takes so much.
They're beefy.
KFP.
I got a coin.
Nice.
Yeah.
You guys, I'm taking the BL.
Oh, wait.
I just saw that there's...
Okay.
Now...
Sorry.
I'm...
I'm like observing even more.
Now there's...
I see the six slots for the items.
Yippee.
Yeah.
Oh, my gosh.
Come on.
Pass away.
Death.
Oh, I guess they're kind of already dead.
But...
Oh.
That was close.
Oh, my God.
Wait.
Oh, no.
Oh.
Always love the surprise.
People are like...
That's what people have for the first KFP.
Face mask.
Multiply all damage dealt by 1.3 times and increase haste by 10%.
Take 30% more damage.
Oof.
Do I want to add an extra book?
I think I shouldn't...
Oh.
This is attack area.
Yeah.
Deadbeats.
Oh.
Oh, my gosh.
They scared me.
Yeah.
Books.
Read.
Oh.
What's that?
What is...
Oh.
Hamburger.
I'll take that.
Oh.
That's health.
I'm guessing.
Oh, gosh.
We're getting a little...
Oh.
That was...
Yes.
Okay.
Mm.
Burger.
We did get the explosion.
We did get the explosion, which is pretty good.
Oh.
I think, though I should increase my weapon damage.
Yes.
So let's do that.
Let's just kind of...
Because...
Yeah.
Being able to kill these guys, like, one...
Oh.
Oh, my gosh.
Being able to kill these guys in one shot would be really helpful.
Max weapon is always good.
I agree.
That's actually how I do try to play these kinds of games too.
So I like kind of focus on one thing.
We got two new things here.
Nurse's horn.
A certain sensei.
When defeating a target, their 30% chance to lifesteal.
Create an area of miasma.
Miasma is acting up.
Okay, actually wait.
This is kind of exactly...
Like I said, I like the books.
I like kind of the...
Oh, but this is nice though.
I have another question.
Are there drops?
Do they have...
Are some drops more common than other drops?
In terms of weapons or stuff like that?
Or is it pretty much all around equal?
So yes.
Kinda.
Yes and no.
Okay.
It's all equal.
Oh, it's random.
Okay.
That makes sense then.
Full random.
Okay.
I don't know which one I want more!
The items you want never show up.
Isn't that just how life is?
Two is rarer?
Okay.
Let's go with two then.
Oh, hello.
My goodness.
Meow!
Oya!
Sorry, Yago.
Oh, sorry, Yago!
Oya!
I'm trying to get this guy out of here.
Oh my gosh!
I'm surrounded, you guys!
Oh, we got it!
Psycho axe.
Throw an axe that spirals outward from the player.
You'll like four?
Four is what you like?
It is?
Hi man, did you watch the Sonic 3 trailer?
You know what?
I actually haven't!
Oh my gosh.
And I have a friend.
She's going to kill me for not watching it yet.
But... I have not watched the new Sonic trailer yet.
But I've heard good things, I think.
Four and book farewell.
Okay.
I'm trusting you guys.
Even though I really want to actually take this one.
But I'm trusting.
I'm trusting.
Oh!
Delivery!
Milk!
Superman?
Oh wait, really?
Streamer lack?
Yippee!
I'll take it then.
Oh my gosh.
Oh, I got a... I got a...
Open a super box.
I got an achievement even for it.
Oh yeah!
You guys were so right about the axe.
Oh my gosh.
Oh my gosh!
Workaholic.
That's very suiting for Calliope, isn't it?
Reach target defeated.
Increase attack by 2% for 2 seconds.
For 4 seconds up to 40%.
I didn't even read what the milk did.
I'll be honest.
I just grabbed it.
I think I'm going to go with the scythe though.
Having the time between attacks reduced is pretty good.
I think I'm going to...
It's a max level.
What's the max level actually?
What is the max level?
Seven.
Okay.
Thank you guys.
Glow stick!
Throw a glow stick to a nearby target and then spins...
So it's like a...
It's like a boomerang?
7 for weapons, 3 for items.
Gotcha.
I'm going to go then with the axe.
Yeah!
Also, do the boxes just have health in them?
Or... usually?
Or is that like... kind of the general idea?
Oh!
The Togodachi!
Oh my gosh.
Wait, wait, wait!
No, no, no, no!
Ouch!
Ah!
Health or XP.
Gotcha.
Milk, increase attack range.
Oh!
Nice.
Beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep!
Eeeek!
I'm just collecting my...
What I've dropped earlier.
These games are always so addicting.
You just can...
It's very easy to just kind of pick them up, you know?
When you're like...
When you're just hanging around.
And just... you can like play a game for like...
You can play a game for like a half hour or like three hours, you know?
Let's go for the scythe.
We're almost close to maxing it.
So...
Look at that guy!
So cute!
Oh!
Giant Togodachi!
I just realized...
Are the...
The wormy looking guys...
Are those chum buds?
I feel bad for not noticing soon.
I thought it was like...
Oh my gosh!
Yeah!
Oh god!
I really kind of...
Hurt myself there.
They're the shrimps?
Oh, okay.
I need health!
Yeah!
Gosh!
There's so many guys!
Come from all sides!
Yeah!
Oh my gosh.
Okay.
We're gaining health though.
We're doing alright.
Oh, here we go.
There we go.
Oh!
Nice.
You can see items and skill descriptions at the menu anytime.
Oh!
Awesome!
Thank you!
Um...
I'm gonna go with this one because...
Hmm...
Wait.
Two?
What's two?
Targets with...
Oh!
This one!
It's just like a skill.
You guys said that this one doesn't take up any slots, so...
Let's go for it!
Oh!
I see it!
I'm going in!
I'm being greedy!
Oh!
The scythe!
Is this...
Wait.
What is this?
This isn't the max level, is it?
Scythe swing awaken?
Is this the max level?
Yeah!
Oh!
Yippee!
Super body pillow!
How
do you guys know if it's like a...
If it's like a really good pull or not?
Wandering taco!
Thanks for the...
It's the lights?
Oh!
I see.
Um...
Gain a shield that absorbs...
Oh!
I guess I'll take it.
Why not?
You know?
Oh!
Oh my gosh!
Eww!
Oh!
They look so... creepy crawly.
With the little shrimps.
They look so creepy crawly.
You're a zoo!
I'm not casually using a baller luck for the gear, but...
I'm not even like noticing...
I'm not...
I'm just here!
Okay?
Okay, out here rigging... Go with one.
Reach target defeated and increase attack by 2% for 4 seconds, up to 40%.
What's headphones?
15% chance to negate one hit.
Create a shockwave that knocks back all targets.
I kind of want to level up my healing, but so far we're doing all right.
So I'll try one.
I'll listen to you guys for now.
I know nothing, so... I'll follow your advice.
I'll follow your advice a little bit.
You know, whatever.
Oh, the Maiaizama!
Okay, I kind of want to take this one.
Okay.
Yes!
Thanks for the 10 gifted!
The super items only have a 5% drop rate.
Wait, really?
Maiaizama.
Oh my gosh.
Touhou Dodge.
Oh, there's so many things circling me.
This is what always gets me about these games too, though.
There's so many things that end up circling that it's hard to...
view what is going on the screen.
You know what I mean?
How much luck did you get from your hololoshes?
I can't help it.
I'm just a simp, you know?
We're still okay on health, so let's...
do that.
Well, increase...
Increase attack in all fields.
Increase attack...
Attack, attack, attack.
Oh no, no, no!
Giant!
Giant shrimp.
Giant shrimp, giant shrimp, giant shrimp!
Thank you!
Yeah, I'm a simp.
You know, when I first created that...
That voice line...
It's supposed to be for everybody else, you know?
For you guys, but in the end...
You're a simp.
You're a soup.
It only just ended up describing myself.
It's like me calling myself a simp.
Basically.
This guy is relentless.
Oh, dippy!
Chat reflects the streamer.
What's this?
Oh, the pickup range!
Hollow bomb.
A bomb that explodes, dealing damage to all nearby targets.
Remove hit limit.
There's a hit limit on it?
Is the bomb not that good?
I like the pickup range.
Go for skills.
Bomb's okay.
Okay, okay, okay.
Two is a trap.
Anything but two!
Okay.
We'll go for five.
Oh!
Yippee!
Super headphones!
You guys, I think it's...
Is the game broken?
How did I get three in a row?
Are you playing an old version?
No!
I just... I just got this yesterday.
I'm worried for your safety.
Should I just take it then?
I guess I should take all the super stuff, shouldn't I?
Rigged!
What are you talking about?
Who's rigging this?
No!
If I dropped it, it would make you guys feel better?
Make you guys feel better?
Since I'm like...
You guys are like, she's cheating!
No!
It's hurting!
All healing is doubled!
It's an eye...
No?
Let's...
Let's go for workaholic.
We'll up...
We'll up that skill.
I'm taking my money.
I'm taking all your money.
I'm taking the money.
Okay.
Oh, this is all new stuff.
Okay, interesting.
Drop lava on the ground.
Oh, I like ones like that too!
Three?
Okay, I'm glad we're all in agreement then.
Wow!
Oh!
The extra strong chumboids.
Why are they closing in so slow?
They're closing in so slow.
Oh, wait.
They're not even closing in.
Never mind.
Donating a little luck so nothing bad happens.
I seriously don't know, you guys.
I don't know.
Maybe my game is borked.
I have no idea.
Three?
Yeah, you know what?
It's time that we level up our BL book.
We can get some additional in here.
Give us a little bit of a boost, you know?
Give me...
your money.
Bye!
Okay, there we go.
Gosh!
Oh gosh, they're so fast.
Coin!
Does the...
I'm guessing the coins unlock new people.
I was gonna say characters, but like...
It's kinda weird to call them characters, right?
Gosh!
Oh, it's gotcha!
Uh-oh.
Oh, boar sheep!
Every 10 seconds, food will drop close by.
We also still have one weapon slot left.
Let's go with the...
Let's go with upgrading this, cuz...
Oh my gosh.
She's huge!
The bat is so menacing.
Oh my gosh.
Sorry, I'll go.
Oh, I destroyed the Yaogo statue.
Oh, gosh, they're mad at me.
Wait.
I see an angry taco.
Oh, gosh.
Oh my gosh, oh my gosh, I'm trying to juke through these guys.
Holy cow!
I'm trying to juke through them!
Oh my gosh.
It's okay, health is still fine.
Health is decent.
Why are the tacos so angry at me?
We're still okay, we're still okay.
Give me more coins!
Coins!
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
I'd like to know who is responsible for the spider cooking.
And who is carrying the bucket of lava.
Follow the arrow?
Oh, okay, so we...
Okay, I was gonna say, I don't see him anymore.
So I must have killed him.
I didn't see the arrow.
I see it now though, thank you guys.
Oh, my nose is so clogged up.
Hold on, let me take a sippy.
Let's go for it.
Oh, I thought you meant like, who is...
Who is carrying these like, in-game.
Yeah, no, the spider cooking is hachama.
What's the bucket of lava though?
Oh, lava is miko.
I see, I see.
Okay, surely...
Surely, my luck cannot be like, so crazy, you know?
Open!
Okay, you guys see?
I'm not hacking!
See?
Nothing of the sort.
Okay, they found out.
Shut it down, shut it down.
They found out.
We got too greedy.
Turn it off.
She toggled it.
Let's go with the bucket.
Lava.
Oh, I got an achievement.
Don't take any damage for five minutes.
Wow!
Oh, no, not the plug.
Fire a fast piercing tail targeted at a random target.
I think I'll still go with this one.
We'll go with death again.
Oh, my gosh.
Oh, go with nurse's horde.
Yeah!
Okay, boss battle time.
I think.
Maybe.
Probably.
Is this boss battle?
I guess.
Fubuzilla.
Oh.
Yeah!
Toho.
I see it.
Rainbow.
Yeah.
See, this is kind of like why I like to have kind of a barrier around me.
Because with things like this, I can use my big attacks to focus on the main enemy.
And then we get it done, baby.
We get it done, baby.
Let's...
Increase damage by 30%.
Oh, it went up a little bit.
You know what?
We'll do that one.
Delivery.
Oh, three of them.
Yippee.
Dun, dun, dun.
One more book.
Okay.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
Oh, okay.
I couldn't see my cursor for a second.
What are you talking about?
It wasn't even a special one, you guys.
Head.
Oh, wait.
I was going to do this one, but...
Throw two lava.
No, I think I'll go with the BL book.
We'll focus on getting the BL book as much as we can.
Duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh.
Minto, stop hacking.
If only my gacha luck was as good as this for Blue Archive.
I want good gacha luck, you guys.
Wait, what are these things?
It's kind of hard.
Oh, oh, just kidding.
They're...
I see.
They're the little rats.
Little bay rats.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, gosh.
I couldn't see my...
I couldn't see my cursor for a second.
Oh, gosh.
Um...
Oh!
Attack up.
The brats.
Hmm.
Okay, so we're either going to have to take a new item...
Oh, I have two slots for items.
Okay.
It's only one slot for...
Let's see.
Um...
Gain 1% gold.
I'm going to crit buff every 10 seconds, up to 10.
If we get a stat up, though...
That doesn't take any extra...
I guess...
I mean...
I'm just...
You guys, I'm like so picky about...
This is how I am in these types of games.
I'm like, oh, but like, I have to save these slots for like...
What if something I really, really want, you know?
Healing is doubled.
One is okay.
If eating food, 5% crit for 10 seconds.
Uber sheep every 10 seconds.
Oh, the food drop.
You know what?
Let's go with Uber sheep, because these are both healing.
You heal enough.
I know.
I'm not really taking any damage.
So maybe, actually, this one would be better.
Maybe the sake would be better.
Yeah, I don't really need healing, huh?
Well, what if I do...
I don't know.
I can't get cocky, you guys.
That's when it gets bad.
Oh, what's this?
Upgrade!
The BL book.
But what if I use it on...
You guys, I can still buy, or, you know, I can...
The BL book still has upgrades.
But this one, I can get an extra thing for my scythe.
The scythe can't be...
I can't upgrade it anymore unless it's with this, I'm guessing, right?
Book is still priority?
BL is zero cost.
Does this cost something?
Scythe uses gacha money.
Oh!
Okay.
Wait, hold on.
Let me see.
It won't let me undo.
Oh, okay.
There we go.
Okay, okay.
Oh, use an anvil!
Yippee!
Goodbye, little rat.
Oh my gosh.
This is when the game starts getting really satisfying, you know?
When you're just like, plowing through everything.
And it's just like, so satisfying to watch everything go down.
They're just slicing and dicing.
And it feels so...
So good.
How long are these levels?
I thought that it was...
I thought it would have been done by Iago.
I thought it would have been done after Fubuzilla.
Hi, Minto.
Sorry I couldn't read the rest of your super chat, but thank you!
Hello!
20 minutes?
Oh, okay.
That's not bad.
We're almost there.
Oh!
Spider cooking!
Fubuzilla was the mini-boss!
Okay.
I see.
Minto.
That's me.
I'm Minto.
Oh my gosh.
The books are so awesome.
Crony's clocks are just...
Oh!
Big clock.
I saw him spawn.
Okay, here we go.
Yeah!
Take him out!
Lead him to the lava!
Oh, just kidding.
Oh, leave it...
Lava, lava, lava, lava, lava, lava.
Oh, just kidding.
Come on.
Back in the lava!
Oh, yippee!
King Rolex.
Oh, there's an arrow.
Thank you.
I'm gonna still go with the spider cooking.
I see the arrow down there.
Oh, it's an anvil.
Nice!
Small knockback.
Let's see.
BL book?
Gold anvil?
It doesn't look gold to me.
The pink anvil?
Pink arrow?
Did I miss?
The lava.
Oh, wait.
How do I...
Oh, there we go.
Plus 50!
Oh, just kidding.
This one.
There we go.
I see.
It costs 50.
It's a little pricey.
Where's the pink?
Oh, I see it!
I see it!
Okay.
Up here!
Wow!
What is...
Oh!
These two collab?
Can you collab anything or does it have to be certain things?
Certain things.
Got it.
BL fujoshi!
Endless BL!
How shameless!
Wow!
Oh!
I feel invincible right now, you guys.
How shameless.
Just all this BL on my stream.
Okay.
That's where my cursor is.
I couldn't find it for a second.
Oh.
Everybody's all strong now though.
Lava!
Q time?
What's that mean?
Q?
Time for Q?
What do you mean?
What's that mean?
What's going on?
Oh my gosh!
Hahaha...
Yippee!
Oh!
Yes!
The saw!
Okay.
I thought you were...
I thought you guys meant like...
You can press Q on your keyboard.
Which one do I want to do?
Let's get the wrapper up.
Eat all that.
Let's go for the bucket of lava.
I do want to get that one.
As max as possible.
The bucket.
Giant Debut.
I just noticed him.
There's two of them!
Get him in the lava.
Nice.
Level 6.
Here we go.
Oh my gosh.
Ouchie.
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
Oh my gosh.
I didn't realize the chum bud was still alive.
Okay.
Bucket max, baby.
Yippee!
Some people are just kidding.
I don't think I should take it.
Should I take it?
I don't know if I should take it.
What if I get something else that I want?
Makes a good collab.
Okay.
You know what?
I should probably just try out everything that I can, you know?
And we have this one as well.
Take it.
Might as well.
Defeated Golden Yago.
Which I don't even know what just happened.
Everything happened so fast.
Everything happened so quickly.
I can combine these.
Is this worth it?
Yeah.
What is this?
May have severe unknown side effects if consumed.
I don't even know what it created.
Oh.
Oh, it's like...
Oh my gosh.
What are these?
Oh god.
Elite cooking.
They have their little shield.
It's so cute.
How am I not taking damage?
Is my question.
Sometimes.
Sometimes I take damage, obviously.
But like sometimes I'm just walking right on top of these guys and I'm not taking any damage.
There we go.
Get me out of this.
Get me out of here.
The body pillow.
That's right.
It does absorb.
I forgot about that.
Let's see.
We're plugging it up, baby.
I'm such an offense over defense believer.
Like I'm such a like a...
I will fire everything and have nothing to defend me.
Valid.
Ubersheet, please.
Okay.
Dang it.
Next one, I'll do the Ubersheet.
Oh, I'm stuck on a tree.
Let's see.
It's hard to tell.
In the grassy areas, if there's stuff that I've missed, you know.
Oh.
Oh my gosh.
We're aiming.
Yeah.
Ubersheet.
Boop.
You guys, I wasted up all my gotcha look.
There's a slider for attack opacity.
Oh, really?
That would be great.
Is it...
I know that this is a problem with these kinds of games.
But is it making the bit rate like all funky on your guys' end?
Why are the...
Sana lights so huge?
Why are the Sana lights so huge?
You know one song that I still listen to like probably near daily is Astro Girl.
I love that song so much.
It's so cute.
It's like a...
Because Sana is big.
You're so right.
My mistake.
Anvil?
Oh I see.
I see the arrow.
Thank you.
Yeah.
Don't be afraid to call things out like that.
Oh my gosh.
Uh.
Sucky.
Um.
Guess it would be the best to...
A sheep?
Really?
Keep doing sheep?
Okay, I'll keep doing sheep.
I'm listening to you guys since it's my first time playing.
Literally first...oh gosh!
I'm trying to get...there was a bunch of stuff out there!
Why is everybody so big?!
Okay, wait a second.
Or am I shrinking?
You guys, either I'm shrinking...
or...this world...
is growing.
Now we only have 30 seconds left.
I believe we can make it.
Right!
Right guys!
Oh my gosh, look at all of them.
It's insanity in there.
It's insanity in there!
Oh gosh.
Usha.
Oh god!
Oh my gosh.
Oh my gosh!
Ame!
Where she comes?
Yeah!
Where's my mouse?
There it is.
Okay.
Eat over 50 hamburgers!
Hamburger country, yeah!
What are you trying to say?
Game?
Don't shame me for eating over 50 hamburgers.
I'm just saying.
Oh my gosh.
Back at my maid cafe, there's like a hamburger place I go to.
Not like...so often.
But you know...
I like to have their hamburgers.
And...
And I miss it so much.
She do be jumpin' though.
She do be hoppin' and sittin' and ground-pounding.
Oh!
Yippee!
Here, Minty.
You can have a cheeseburger.
Thanks.
Best first run ever.
Murphy!
What the heck did you...
Oh my gosh.
You changed your profile picture.
Thanks for the painting of the wood!
Okay, so I probably have to go to what character select?
New unlocks.
Energy drink.
Increase haste by 10%.
Speed by 40%.
Reduce max HP.
Research is called game.
1% XP.
You're up soon.
Minto gaming real.
I guess it helps that I've like played this kind of game before, you know?
Sorry.
Oh gosh.
Hold on, let me blow my nose.
Don't mute.
Sorry.
Okay, hold on.
Let me do it again.
Allergies.
No, I just have a bit of a cold.
Is all.
I just have a bit of a cold.
Is all!
The transparency of the weapons.
Yeah.
It's hard.
Sometimes I'm like, where's my mouse?
Because I can't find it.
Wow!
Thank you for the echo!
Why does it seem to be super chat time game?
What are you talking about?
Oh.
Okay.
1% XP.
I'll read it later.
Fan beam.
Shoot a powerful laser beam from the microphone.
Horizontal only.
Okay.
Credit card.
Cost of enhancing.
It's reduced.
It reminds me of when you get Sensei's credit card in Blue Archive.
Stolen piggy bank.
Game 1 coin.
Sorry.
This is so much to read.
Gorilla's paw.
Holo house.
Yay!
Stage 2.
Super chatto time.
Target drops 20% more holocoins.
All holocoins are picked up automatically.
Oh, that's nice.
Uh...
Halu.
Injection type Asakoko.
Oh my god.
It's the Hakkeizo!
Thank you for the Hakkasupa!
Whammy water.
Okay, guys.
Where do I go?
Is it shop?
Character gacha?
Or buy upgrades?
Oh.
But I want a gacha more.
Wait.
Super chatto.
Thank you guys for the super chatto!
Thank you for the Hakkasupa!
Water stop.
Wait.
What's the point of buying Myth when they're already all unlocked?
Get the ultimate first.
Oh.
Oh, costumes.
Outfits.
Oh.
What's in the armory?
These are just the stuff that I've picked up.
Um...
Mock stamp system.
Nyorodo.
Stamps may be dropped by targets which can modify the main weapon.
Specials and stamps are what's good.
Special attack?
Wait.
What was the stamp again?
Unlock the...
Super chatto time?
No!
Growth.
Get stamps?
Yeah, hold on.
Let me just read what...
Eliminate.
Granso use of eliminate on options when leveling up, which can eliminate unwanted items for the runs.
Uh oh.
Reine.
She's amazing at getting more coins.
Hopefully we get her.
Right?
Oh.
There are three tap...
I see it!
Oh.
Oh!
Thank you.
I didn't notice the other tabs.
Oh my gosh.
Increase the difficulty.
Oh...
These are, like, harder.
Refunds all purchases!
Hardcore.
Super items will not drop.
Yo!
If you enchant two weapons and collab them, the collab will have both enchants.
Oh, interesting.
Oh, hold on.
Let me grab the stamps, right?
People mentioned by that.
You guys, I'm wasting all my...
How much... hold on.
How much is a character gacha?
A thousand!
You guys, I'm not gonna have any more!
Now I can gacha?
Serenade?
Fauna?
The tears are a pity system.
What else can you...
Get a random character.
You're always gonna get a character though, right?
Right?
Wait, hold on.
One...
Two, three, four, five, six...
I was gonna say...
I would try for all of them, but I don't have enough.
Like, I would do one from each.
There's no filler?
Okay, good.
Let's just go as many as I can.
Okay, here we go.
Man, I love Fauna.
Yippee!
Oh my gosh.
Oh yeah, people said that I would really like Sauna though, right?
What is Fauna...
What is she like?
Hold on, let me see.
Creates three razor-sharp leaves that spiral...
Wait.
Hold on.
And then summons a giant tree that creates a healing zone?
Oh my gosh.
Fauna seems kinda OP.
That is my AFK strat.
Fauna is fun.
Okay, let's keep going though.
I'm not done.
I'm gonna use all my coins, don't worry.
Five bucks for the Fauna pool.
It was literally free.
I kinda like gamers though.
I like Korone.
Waifu over meta, everybody.
Me too.
Go for Aqua?
Let's try Aqua.
Shubaru!
It's because the game is sensing the hollow tori.
You know?
The game is sensing hollow tori.
Shubashuba!
Shubashubashuba!
Let's try for Reine too.
Since everybody said that she's pretty good.
Hold on.
Oh, I meant to go look at what...
There was a very fast baseball in front.
Also, I didn't read the second...
Like these.
Were they here before?
Okay.
Oh, okay.
Oh, so it's because I just unlocked it.
Got it, got it.
Okay, so these are the special skills.
Create a very loud scream in front.
Knocking back and dealing 120% damage.
Summon daggers that fly forward.
Funya transforms into a living dagger.
Becoming invincible for 10 seconds.
Holy cow.
Okay, we still have three more.
I'll try again for Sana.
Oh,
that's not what I meant to do.
We're moving.
You know what?
Let's just try gamers.
And then I'll do Gen 1.
Just for the heck of it.
Okay.
Ta-da.
Nope.
Nice.
Let's see how they are.
Shoots a few times and aim direction.
At least we got a new person every time.
Releases short discharge that deals 300% damage.
For eight seconds, Roboco gains 100% attack speed, pickup range, and 50% crit in haste.
Okay, okay.
Throws an Onigiri in an arc.
For six seconds, Aokigyou is invincible and increases speed.
Speed by 50%.
I have a question about the skills.
Are they like, automatic?
Or do you trigger them?
A spacebar!
It's a cooldown.
Got it, got it, got it.
Shoot a bunch of feathers at a spread.
Pierces through targets.
Sorry, I was writing it.
Destroy all targets in sight.
Increase haste by 1% for each target as a sacrifice.
Yeah, yeah, sorry.
The ult.
Yeah, yeah.
Maybe I want to try Mumei.
I think.
I mean, sorry, not Mumei.
Sorry, Fauna.
I think I want to try Fauna.
And... buy enchantments.
Oh yeah, we still have a little bit more.
What is this one?
Oh, enchantments.
Yeah, you know what, let's just buy...
Oh, it's 1000.
No!
Okay, I can't buy it, but that's okay.
Oh, the opacity.
How is... where is that under?
Under the graphics, I'm guessing?
Oh, attack opacity.
Maybe like that?
Oh yeah, what's hollow house?
Oh!
Wait, what is this?
We'll try Fauna.
Hollow house is addiction.
What is it?
Oh, it's a custom... Okay, yeah.
It's a customizable house.
Wait, I want Kiwawa then.
Guru is here.
What's this?
Oh, oh, oh, oh!
I got a clownfish!
Wait, come on.
Oh...
Wait...
Tulina!
Shrimp!
Tulina times 2...
Is this all that there is to do in here?
Because this is great.
Oh, I pressed the... I pressed the...
Oh, wait, wait!
Oh, Guru left.
She saw me struggling.
I've been fishing for too long.
FIVE COLD CLOWNFISH!
There's a bunch?
Oh.
Hold on, one more.
One more.
Tuna...
We're gonna end on a win.
Three shrimp!
Oh, look at them!
Wait, what's this?
That's mine.
Hello.
What are you trying to grab?
Oh, she loves me!
She loves me!
Wait,
I have more coins!
What is she trying to grab?
Oh, food.
Cook?
Tempura?
Tuna sandwich!
Oh, they're waving at me.
I thought they were like...
I don't know.
You know.
Trying to grab me or something.
Wow!
This is so relaxing.
Peckle, peckle.
Sorry, pal.
This road is closed for now.
The Usada Casino is still under construction.
Probably won't be done for some more months.
Oh wait, our enemy is gonna come out and attack us.
Why don't you come back another time?
Okay, Peckle.
Save us!
She's working us to death, Peckle!
For the princess, Peckle!
Oh gosh, this Peckle is...
Oh no, the snow soggy is dead!
Oh wait!
Oh wait, is that a rock?
I can't do it!
Dead body or rock?
I can't tell!
Wait!
Oh, I can go into the forest a little bit.
Moe-Mate!
Hello!
What's over here?
Nothing.
Oh!
Bye, Moe-Mate!
Bye, Moe-Mores!
I want the casino!
Wait!
Kay, are you guys adding, like, blood?
Blackjack?
Are you guys adding blackjack to the game?
I mean...
What's this?
Bye?
Oh no!
There's so much hair!
Hair!
Wait, is it inside my house?
Is that what I decorate in here?
No furniture!
Steal fish from another member?
Oh, I think she's mad at me.
Sorry.
Oh, never mind.
She's happy!
She loves me!
Sorry.
I didn't mean to steal your fish.
She can have this one.
She can have... Oh, sorry.
Oh my gosh.
I'm... I'm... I'm throwing.
Here you go!
She'll definitely want these ones.
No!
She left!
What's this?
Bye.
Dad's rod!
Golden rod!
Exchange?
I don't have any dirt.
You made her cry.
No!
Oh!
Huh?
Can I keep going up?
Nope.
Is there anywhere else that I can explore?
How do I get rid of the fish?
Where do I sell the fish at?
Sell here?
Oh!
Oh, so you can catch it or you can cook it.
I see, I see.
Now I have dirt.
Okay.
Oh, I need so much dirt for Dad's rod!
Dang it.
Talk to all the NPCs.
I think I have.
Or did I miss anybody?
Oh, there's the billboard.
Or bulletin board.
Hire.
Send out an advertisement to get recruits.
For what?
There's a talk option.
Wait, what are you talking about?
Oh, here?
Oh, you're right!
Good day to you.
I'm Nemu!
I'm looking after this farm for Fada!
Oh my gosh, my Kamiyoshi's name is Nemu.
Here you can help raise crops to use however you'd like.
As a representative of Mother Nature herself, we would be happy for you to help us grow all sorts of different plants.
To get started, you can buy some special farming soils as well as seeds from me.
Then simply select one of the eight farming spots and then choose a combination of soil and seed.
Of course, plants will take some time to grow, but don't worry.
If you decide to go somewhere else, I'll look over the plants for you while you're gone.
They'll continue to grow.
Now, all plants love water as it helps them grow, so if you take time to water the plants, they will grow faster.
Thanks to my special magic, the plants on this farm will never die, so you can rest easy.
By the way, I have three different kinds of soils you can buy.
Our standard soil has no special properties, but it's very cheap and affordable.
Then we have our expedited soil, which speeds up plant growth by 40%.
You just left it there!
What are you doing?
She's mad at me!
I'll make kills for sport.
I'm taking what she's having.
Whatever she grabs.
There she goes.
Into the forest.
Into the woods.
Never to be seen again.
Read.
You read the notes written on the bulletin board.
Here you can recruit volunteers looking for work.
These workers will help you slowly make money, just as long as you keep them well-fed.
First, you will have to pay an initial...
Oh my gosh, it's raining!
So cute!
...an initial cost to send the workers home.
Then, as long as they have the stamina, they will continue working by themselves and generate holocoins for you, whether you are here or not.
Wow!
Workers are all different and have their own strengths and weaknesses.
Workers have the following stats.
Stamina, how long they can work before they become exhausted.
I mean...
Exhausted is like...
It's subjective, right?
Exhausted is subjective, right?
If they can...
You know...
If they have legs, then they can work!
How many holocoins they can gather at once.
How quickly the workers can grow and improve.
The limit a worker can grow to.
As you feed your worker, not only do they recover their stamina, but they will also gain EXP.
After gaining a certain amount of EXP, a worker will level up and increase their base stats, such as stamina and efficiency.
...
Like a herdsman!
Sort of.
Okay next.
Is everything okay today?
What happened this morning?
How are you.
My name is I'll take your place for a moment.
Your name is  It's a direct reflection.
I watch you.
What are you doing?
domlegiri It's me, Do Allies!
And so do I.
Yes, it is.
I'm very.
How silly.
I liked that.
Scatter!
Literally fades into the bushes.
Okay.
This was very cute.
I liked that.
But I do want to play more.
Play stage mode.
I want to play the hollow office.
I want to play as Fauna.
I want to try.
I'll do my best.
Oh, it says recommended upgrades.
Maybe I should do the upgrades then.
Let me hold on.
I think I have enough.
Don't I?
Yeah.
Oh!
How did I get so much money?
Wait, where did all this money come from?
Where did all this money come from?
The fish!
Attack level 2.
This is, I'm guessing, level 1.
Right?
So that's level 2.
And then what was the other one?
Speed?
Okay.
And then I can also buy...
Oh wait, this one.
Yippee!
Okay.
Let's go.
I'm just going to try it.
I'm just going to try it, okay?
We're just going to try it.
If we die, we die.
Oh, there's no, like, aiming because...
I guess that makes sense.
Oh my gosh, Fauna.
Her attacks, like...
It's so, it's so wide of a range.
Nice!
Oh, the click to aim!
That's right!
I forgot about that.
Wow, there's so many new things!
When healing, a branch will grow under a random nearby target, dealing 200% damage.
Aww.
So, each character also has their own set of, like...
Okay.
The skills and stuff.
Defeated targets have a 5% chance to drop saplings.
Sapling heals 3% and increases Fauna's attack and speed.
Ooh, that seems good.
I see a lot of people saying 3.
I think it's probably good to go and...
aim for leveling up the base weapon first.
I get it.
I get it, you guys.
It's usually how I play, anyway.
So...
Oh, that's right.
I need to...
You know what?
In fact, I'm even.
Oh, but the Psycho Axe!
It does reduce the time...
Oh, it was messaging me.
Oh my gosh, hold on.
Still one?
Okay.
Oh, there it is.
The left click.
Am I actually aiming, though?
I don't think I am.
Hahaha.
Oh, I don't really need the health, but whatever.
I don't think I'm actually aiming.
It's fine, though.
I just like to have it.
Oh, oop, oop, oop, oop.
Two additional leaves!
There we go.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Give me that.
Oop!
Ouchie ouch!
Oh, what's that?
What's this?
A haste up stamp.
Place this...
Oh?
What do I do?
Oh!
Apply?
Hmm?
Confirm?
Finish?
Oh my gosh, this level is so narrow.
Okay.
Hahaha.
This level is so narrow.
Oh, there's something else up there.
What's that?
Is that another stamp?
Oh!
Increase damage 5% for each empty weapon slot.
It's good now.
Yes.
It's good right now.
Am I able to get rid of them once I...
Yeah, you can?
Okay, cool.
Nice.
Oh!
Hahaha.
This level is so narrow.
Oh, health.
Let's grab it.
Yeepee!
Nature shield awakened.
All right, guys.
Whoa!
Oh my god.
Hahaha.
Here they come.
Here we go.
Save that Borg.
A little bit.
Oh, no.
Okie dokie.
You lose 5% HP every second?
Oh my gosh.
That's insanity.
Now, gain 1% EXP for 2 seconds when HP is full.
The EXP slowly increases.
Oh!
Let's try it.
Yeah.
Getting more EXP sounds good.
In my opinion.
What's on TV?
We got Koyori.
Volca.
Laplace.
Roboco.
I don't know.
What's on TV?
Everything is on TV, you guys.
They can't make up their mind.
They're just...
They're going through everything.
It's literally whatever you want is on TV.
Oh my gosh.
Oh!
Yippee!
Huh?
They got the slideshow.
Hahaha.
When in danger, use the ultimate.
Yes.
It's space, right?
It's space.
Oh!
The sapling!
Yeah.
Let's go with the sapling.
Yippee!
Hahaha.
I shall take it.
But I don't want to...
The sapling...
Oh!
Look how cute he is!
I don't want to take too many weapons right now just because we...
Um...
We have the...
That one skill.
That one stamp, right?
So...
Oh my goodness.
Get out of my way.
Get out of my way!
Put him in the soup.
Hahaha.
Oh
no!
My psychoaxe!
Ignore the stamp.
Get weapons.
Oh!
Okay.
What did the saplings do again?
It was like healing HP or something.
What the...
Oh!
Scared me.
Stamps can be swapped in and out.
Okay.
I'll remember.
Oh!
Ahem.
It heals and makes you go fast.
Okay.
Cool.
Thank you.
Do we want to...
Defeat targets have a 7% chance of drop sapling, heals, and...
Oh.
That's what I'm gonna go with.
Max out on XP early.
You know what?
That's so true.
It's a good point.
Okay.
Come here, little saplings.
I see you over there.
Weee!
Hahaha.
Oh my gosh.
They're gonna explodey.
Oh!
There's so many coins up here.
Hello?
Jackpot.
Hahaha.
Um...
Oh!
Gain one coin for every 100 pixels traveled.
Huuuh!
Uh-oh.
Use the special?
I don't need to.
Because I'm all full of health.
There's a box to the right.
Oh!
Is there?
I'm gonna do...
Increase my saplings.
Oh!
Wait.
There's a box.
Oh!
Ouch!
Hahaha.
Oh!
There it is.
I see it.
Woah!
Nice.
Okay.
Oh!
You're a specialist surrounded by enemies.
Okay, okay.
Because it grants me invulnerability, right?
You guys just want the Super Chatto time!
Four for gacha.
I want to do the BL book, but...
Okay, okay, okay.
One.
Whoa, what are the stars for?
Hi, dog!
Two!
Love the content.
Hashtag first timer.
Oh, thank you!
Three?
Wait, the guardian tree?
Oh, it increases your ultimate meter.
Got it, got it.
Thanks, guys.
Thank you, thank you!
Okay.
The guardian tree, then.
Three is damage.
One makes three better.
Well, yeah, every 10 seconds gain one whisper.
Each stack heals.
I think we're good on it.
This is... We'll do this one, though.
Yeah, we gotta get these saplings.
Little baby saplings are so lonely.
Whoa!
Oh, that was awesome!
That was the tree branch.
Hiya!
I don't know what they're gonna do.
This.
Okay, okay, I see, I see.
Whoo!
What?
Hyah!
Oh!
Okay, it's like kind of random.
Or maybe, I think.
Super chat time!
I'll take it.
Oh, that lava bucket.
Oh, wait!
Oh!
I think getting more saplings might be good.
Two or four?
Yeah, that's kind of what I'm in between about.
I do want the bucket, but...
I think the bucket is...
Buckets are good in these kinds of areas because they're so contained.
You know, like it's so narrow.
It's good to have something like that.
Five.
Oh, look at you.
The secret option.
Five!
Hmm...
Bucket has an enchant on it.
Maybe I should just grab it.
Since it's here.
Bucket plus axe?
Oh, really?
Okay, I'm just gonna grab it.
I know it's probably not as wise because I should be focusing on enhancing everything else.
And making it stronger rather than, you know...
Yeah...
But... But!
But!
Hear me out.
Super chat time.
It looks like pizza.
It makes me hungry.
Which one should we get?
Maybe the book.
Wait.
Actually, my axe.
Maybe my axe.
The coat?
We can't do the coat.
Oh wait!
Enchant!
Weapon gains random bonus effects.
Is there already bonus effects?
Wait.
What's the bucket's enchant?
Crit damage 10%?
Enchant costs coins.
Oh, okay, okay, okay.
Maybe I should just regular upgrade then right now?
Oh gosh.
All these extra things are hurting my brain.
Hahahaha.
It already has an enchantment.
Oh, is that why it's blue?
And then the BL book also has an enchantment?
So, the axe needs the enchantment!
Ahhh!
250.
Okay.
It's fine.
We got super chat time.
Come here, sapling.
Hehehe.
Cha!
Oh.
Super chat time.
Hehehe.
Eat the pizza.
Woo!
Hohohoho.
Awesome.
I can't.
I haven't forgot about my ult, you guys.
Don't worry.
I'm like saving it.
I'm saving it.
Mmmmmmmm.
This body pillow though...
The body pillow helped me a lot before.
The body pillow helped me a ton.
Anything but three.
Mmmmmmm.
I...
Think I'll go for the sapling.
There we go.
Wohoo!
I'm trying to grab the saplings.
I'm gonna do the BL book this time.
Oh wait, this will be maxed out though.
Okay, never mind.
Just kidding.
I changed my mind.
I'm greedy.
I'm so greedy.
Yeah!
Wait, don't come this way!
Oh gosh, oh gosh.
That was a sapling!
No sapling left behind.
More money!
Oh, everything is new.
Two?
Is Whisperer that good?
It's kinda creeping me out.
Oh, I...
Oh...
It's her skill.
Oh, it is?
Oh, I see it.
It does say skill.
Oh my gosh.
Oh gosh.
Ouchie ouch ouch ouch ouch ouch.
I'm getting greed.
Oh, I'm getting careless.
I'm getting a little careless.
Careless Whisperer.
Ouchie ouch ouch.
Oh my gosh.
Ouch ouch ouch!
You guys, not good.
Not good.
Where's the burger?
Where's the burgers?
Where the burgers at?
I'm trying to grab saplings, but they're so far...
Oh!
Oh my god.
Oh...
Oh,
the special!
Thank you guys.
Okay.
You know how I said I forgot about... I didn't forget about the special earlier?
Wait, is it X or is it space?
Some people said X.
Space?
Okay.
Um...
Uh...
Oh.
Um...
Okay.
Oh, space did not work.
So, maybe it is X.
Yeah,
I'll take it.
Try shift?
Okay.
Or right click?
Shift or right click?
Uh...
Oh!
Yeah!
Oh gosh.
I don't know how long... How long am I invincible for?
Oh, I'm... I don't think I'm invincible anymore?
Psycho Axe.
And we're all healed baby.
Wee!
We are all healed up.
Yummy, yummy sapling.
There's a timer in the bottom left?
Okay, cool.
Thank you.
Whisper.
How do I consume the whisper?
Oh, I see how it works.
Okay.
Will you play Maid of the Dead again soon?
Maybe.
Automatic.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Whisper.
That's me.
Well, you know, that's you actually.
Whispers.
What's this?
Is it because it's a PC?
Not the potato PC.
Attacks have 20% chance to slow targets.
I mean, why not, right?
The pull-tato.
Sorry.
The pull-tato PC.
Yes, yes, yes.
Oh my gosh.
Yowza.
Yowza!
Yow!
Eep.
Nice.
We're slowing them down a little bit.
Okay, cool, cool, cool, cool.
No, no, no.
Oh my gosh.
We took a lot of damage there.
We're not even halfway through the stage.
Maybe I should do uber sheep.
I think I should uber sheep because I'm taking a lot of damage.
Oop.
My bad.
Ubersheep.
I'm guessing these are the onigiri for Okayu.
Oh my gosh.
Ouch!
Who's aiming for me?
Who's attacking me?
Oh my gosh.
My game stuttered.
Come here.
No saplings left behind.
No saplings left behind!
Not the table.
Oh my gosh.
How?
For the skills?
What's the max level they can get?
Need more DPS.
I agree.
So I think I'll go with the book.
Ooh!
Nice, nice.
Oh, nice, nice.
Oh!
Nice, nice.
You guys, I lucked out on those first three boxes and then never again.
Whisper's DPS with the trees.
She speaks for the trees.
Okay, then we'll do Whisper here.
Oh my gosh.
Yago!
Oh, he's dropping cash.
Yippee!
Silver Yago!
Oh, my spider cooking.
Create a splash of unknown water in front.
The whammy water is good.
Sorry.
Oh, choices to make here.
I know.
Oh.
It's either... I feel...
But also the elite lava.
Water and BL is a collab.
But also BL and Axe was a collab, so...
BL water is good.
I guess we haven't seen that one before, so I do want to see it.
We can try it.
Since I haven't seen it, you know?
I'm all for experimenting since I haven't played the game before, you know?
So I want to try out...
Rather than sticking to the same old things just because they worked before, I like to try out different combinations and stuff too, you know?
You know?
Yeah.
I'm gonna go with the water...
Oh, actually, no.
I'm gonna go with the...
Four?
What is four?
Chris, regular friend.
Are you guys trying to kill me?
Yeah, four?
I think you guys are trying to kill me.
I think you guys are literally trolling me right now.
You guys are...
I don't trust you at all.
In this situation.
Please kindly go fuck yourself.
Okay?
Thank you very much for your suggestion.
And also, it has been vetoed.
Wow!
Oh my gosh.
I just right clicked.
You know what?
Actually, this works out.
This is probably a good time to right click.
This is an okay time to right click.
Actually.
Yippee!
Psycho ass.
Yip!
Oh!
Flower.
Weakened stamp.
Attacks have a 20% chance to reduce attack and defense of targets.
Flower.
I guess probably this one.
No!
I think I should sell it though, huh?
But it's just like...
It's just...
Oh, it's so sad in this context.
Oh my god.
Wait.
If you sell it...
Like...
It means it won't drop again in this run, right?
Or forever?
Use it for strengthen.
Ah!
I see.
Okay.
Swap and then use this.
Oh.
Wait.
Ah!
How do I...
Oh!
I see!
Okay.
What was...
Oh, this is the haste.
Um...
Okay.
I get it now.
I get it.
Um...
Probably flower then, right?
Wait.
Reduce the time between...
Oh!
Never mind.
Reduce the time...
Okay.
Never mind.
Yes.
Strength and haste.
For some reason, in my head, I was thinking haste is like...
Is like running speed, you know what I mean?
Oh my god!
Elite!
4 credit card?
No, I think I'm gonna go with...
I'm gonna go with Psycho Axe.
RGB stamp!
Weapon attacks will look pretty.
Which one do I get rid of?
Replace flower with this?
And then...
Oh no!
Oh my gosh, that scared me.
I accidentally closed out of it.
Strengthen it?
Okay.
Nothing will...
What happens if I'm leveling this up?
What are you expecting it to do?
Rainbow harder?
I wanna see a rainbow!
Wow!
It looks so pretty!
Oh my gosh.
Aesthetics are worth it, you guys.
Actually...
Everything is like...
Very hard to see right now.
It does look nice.
It does, yeah.
It does look really nice.
There are no items to steal...
Hmn...
Stay away!
Yyyyyy BOO.
Oh, I didn't mean to grab that.
Oh, there's some...
High-level ones over here.
Oh my gosh, I got stuck on something.
There we go.
Yeah-yeah-yeah.
Whammy water.
Or the axe.
Remove hit limit.
Damn it.
I'm going to go with that one.
Where is Miko?
Oh, there she is.
She's clipping through the table, you guys.
Ah, let's see.
If I upgrade this, it...
It is free.
Yeah!
Okay, run away.
Oh, my lava buckets are looking pretty spicy down there.
We burnted the pizza.
We burnted the pizza!
No!
Wait, no sapling left behind.
I'll come back for you!
Oh my gosh, she's just plowing on through.
There we go.
We got her back, boys!
Oops.
Ouchie, ouchie.
That's not good.
That's her lava?
Wait, what?
Oh!
Oh.
I'm just running on through, thinking that I'm totally fine here.
Oh my gosh, there's so much here.
So I think it's probably good to...
Yes!
Eat it up.
I think I'm going to go for the sake.
Okay.
I can't decide.
Yippee!
Hold on.
One second.
Please don't spam!
Please don't spam.
Sorry.
Don't spam, don't spam.
Sake!
Umm...
Let's do the axe, duh.
There we
go.
I guess it really doesn't...
I don't know why I'm auto-doing it when it really doesn't make a difference, but that's okay.
Umm...
Uh... rope!
So far, so good.
Right, guys?
Moments before disaster.
Okay, now it's just confusing if she has buckets of lava and I have buckets of lava.
Right?
I'm gonna keep leveling up what I have.
And then once I kind of get those things better and more high up, then I shall...
Then I shall focus on new items.
Something missed.
I don't know what it was.
Great!
It really makes me want pizza, but Japanese pizza is not good.
Attacks have a 3% chance to hit holo coins out of target per hit.
Oh, out of targets per hit.
Chance and amount is increased for every 10 damage dealt.
Maybe I get rid of... Swap rainbow!
No!
Maybe we get rid of the PCs.
But the rainbow!
Enhance the rainbow.
Please stop it already.
All the colors... It already has all the colors.
We can't invent new colors.
Yes, you can!
Is it ult time?
Yes.
Oh, I don't have enough for my ult.
No!
Oh gosh.
Please!
Just a little bit more!
And we can use it.
Actually, I think... I think I'm okay.
I think I'm okay.
Not okay.
Okay is a strong word.
We are managing.
Right, everyone?
Look at all these guys.
No saplings left behind.
No saplings left behind!
Water is aimable.
Oh, it is!
Okay.
Good to know.
PL book!
So, the water is... Oh, I see it now.
I see it.
Oh.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh, oh, oh.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Kind of just like chilling in here.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Bucket!
So, like you have... What's it called?
The anvil!
Lava to seven?
Save for lava to seven?
Okay, we're gonna...
Not yet, not yet.
Okay, okay, okay.
Oh my goodness.
I'm trying to like chill in this area, but it's a little scary, you guys!
Six!
Oh, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
Not bad.
There we go.
Don't leave the tree!
Don't leave the...
Tree, don't leave me!
Please survive.
I'm trying.
Oh my gosh.
Okay, I have to leave the anvil, I think.
Give me more food.
I'm trying to grab health.
Oh my god.
Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Okay, okay, okay.
Okay, okay.
Okay.
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
I'm taking a lot of damage, you guys!
Okay.
Take that.
Now we can collaborate because we maxed it.
Okay.
So, which one should I...
Do the...
The lava and the axe?
That's the one we didn't do before, right?
Yeah?
Okay.
Ta-da!
Whoa!
Me cover!
Take it.
Yep.
Holy cow!
Holy...
The biggest pizza.
Delicious.
Oh my gosh.
Okay, I'm trying to get out of here, actually.
Thank you.
Oh my god.
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
Oh, I reached level 50!
Let's max our...
There's a stand to the right?
Where at?
Oh, gosh.
Hold on.
Oh, golden apple!
Are these good?
This is the one that I said I wanted to combine before, right?
So...
Endless waves of ice that slows targets.
Okay...
Oh my god!
No!
I just made it!
I
had this little bit left to be able to use my ult.
We had only a little less than five minutes.
No!
Gotcha.
Okay.
Idol costume.
Good try.
Yeah, that was a good try.
Study glasses.
Breastplate.
Just a bandage.
Okay, I'm gonna close my eyes.
Okay?
I'm gonna close my eyes.
And I'm not even gonna know what I'm picking.
I'm rotating.
I don't even know what I'm picking.
It's the ultimate gacha.
Here!
Oh, I have to open my eyes to buy it.
Let's try!
Suisei!
Yippee!
Sui-chan.
You're so cute today.
Yippee!
Let's have fun!
It was a good buy.
What else?
I still wanna try for Reinae.
What?
My first dupe!
My first dupe.
Get onyed.
Oh no!
I got the tears.
How many tears do you need?
It's literally 2 thirds.
How does this happen?
Seven?
Okay.
Seven.
That's a... that's a Seinfeld joke.
Oh.
Oh, wait.
Oh, the tear?
Oh, I see it now!
Okay.
How did... wait, how did I... did I accidentally... how did I get to that?
How did I get to that screen?
Seinfeld Minto, your age is showing.
Okay, hold on.
To be fair, I watched all of Seinfeld like... it was like... only like a couple years ago.
Asuki is the best coin farmer in this game?
You can get over 1 billion coins!
Is this true, chat?
Is this real?
Minto-chan wa kyou mo kawaii.
Kawaii kunai!
Click on the picture.
Oh, tears menu!
Okay, cool, cool.
Let's try for Asuki then.
Here we go.
Second dupe!
Oh.
Iris is also a coin farmer.
You know what?
I'm trying to also get Sana, so let's just keep going.
Fails!
Here we go.
Baba!
What is happening?
Oops, all dupes.
Okay, to be fair, we have 3 out of 6, so...
There's still so many characters I have to unlock!
I think though today... I know it's a bit of a shorter stream, but I think I'm gonna end it here because I started a bit later.
I'm so sorry, guys!
But I think I'm gonna end it here.
I wanna... oh gosh.
I'm gonna play some off-stream probably.
I say probably, but like... you know.
I wanna test around with stuff and like see what kind of works for me and things that I like and everything, so...
I'll come back and I'll... I'll come back and the whole menu will be complete at this point.
But it's fun if you like big numbers.
Yeah, I wanna try playing everybody and, you know...
Um... like...
How do I say?
On my own time, because...
You know, on stream, if I'm playing every... if I try everybody, that's like 20 minutes around.
It'll just like take forever.
So...
Try Princess, thank you!
Um...
But yeah!
Turning off damage numbers is nice too.
Luckily, this time I didn't feel like there was so much on screen.
A little bit more manageable, because I turned down the opacity, but...
Save Mumei for stream.
Okay.
Sure, sure.
Will I play more of this on stream?
Yeah!
I will.
So, so, so.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Um...
But today, just because I started a bit later...
And I have some other things I need to work on.
So I'm going to head out and do that.
I'm actually not going outside today.
I'm like staying holed up in my hotel room.
Turning off damage numbers can also help with performance.
Oh!
What is...
I'm curious for those who do...
Not the...
What's it called?
Hold on, I'm just going to...
No, for the endless mode!
What is your best time?
Where's the leaderboards actually?
Wait.
How do I change it?
45 minutes?
40 minutes?
Wow.
50 minutes?
Click stage 1.
Wait...
Oh, oh, oh, oh...
BibuXX underscore biburocks underscore xx.
I can't tell if this is...
This has to be endless, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
49 minutes?
So edgy.
If it's Bibu, then...
40 minutes?
42 minutes?
All of you saying, I'm not... Oh wait, this is Amelia Watson.
Hold on, maybe I should try...
I was gonna say, you guys out here with like...
You're like, I've done 45 minutes.
Where are you then?
Where are you on the leaderboard?
What's your...
What's your main?
And don't tell me it's a character.
And don't tell me it's a person that I haven't unlocked.
Because that's just cheating.
50 minutes?
Okay.
50 minutes here too.
You wouldn't know my man.
Iris?
No, I don't have Iris!
What about Fauna?
Let's see.
51 minutes!
Player!
This Anno person is everywhere.
They're a big fan.
36, 30...
Oh, I was looking at time.
Wait, hold on, I wanna see...
Oh, I was gonna say, where am I?
I'm gonna do endless.
Maybe, should I do...
Wait, you guys...
Should we do endless and see how...
193!
I don't think we're gonna get very far.
Oh...
I wanna get on the daily ranking.
Stage 1.
Wait, stage 1.
Oh, this is daily.
No!
I don't think I'll get in the...
I realize it's not time at score.
Which makes more sense.
I don't think I'll get...
But I could get... I could do stage 2, you guys.
And get in the...
We'll get in the ranking because...
I might be 4th, but you know...
I'll be... You know what?
Let's just...
Let's go do it.
Okay.
Fauna...
Endless mode...
Stage 2.
It doesn't matter how long I last.
It doesn't matter because...
I'll be up there anyway.
Don't play it!
You guys, if you are playing it right now...
Please...
Let me have this.
Let me...
Let me have just this, okay?
Please, let me just have this!
Please!
Just for...
Just for one game.
Just for like...
Let me screenshot it and then...
And then...
It's fine.
You can beat me.
It's whatever.
But let me have it just for a second, okay?
Let me have it for just a second!
Let me have it for just a second.
Don't snipe!
Don't snipe, please!
Please!
No!
Don't dunk on me!
Oh, I have to pay attention.
You guys are making me lose control!
Please!
Oh my gosh.
Don't make me...
Please, guys.
Please.
Oh my gosh.
We're a little trapped here.
This is fine.
This is...
They just...
Which...
Which version is this?
This is the most updated because I downloaded it yesterday onto my laptop.
Got to get the screenshot.
Yes!
Exactly!
Okay.
If I die now, I'll probably get fourth.
What's my rank?
Come on.
Rank me.
Okay.
I think my score is 195.
No way.
Okay.
Hold on.
We have to see it.
We have to see it fast!
Fourth spooky number!
Okay.
That was it.
That was the grand finale.
Scream.
Scream shot.
Yeah.
Let me take that screenshot real quick.
Thank you.
Kiss.
Perfect.
I got it.
No.
Thank you.
Just...
I just wanted to say, as someone that was never into idols before getting to VTubers, having the chance to see you in concert and shout along to the Hamtaro theme was a dream come true.
Miss Kitsune, I love you.
So happy.
Thank you.
Heretic, thank you.
Hi Mint.
I love you.
Will you marry me?
Platonically.
What benefits can we get out of this platonic marriage?
I'm the worldwide...
I'm sorry.
I'm the world wife...
World wife Mintoa.
I think.
Divorce.
I also did four VTuber concerts in three days and felt like my arms are going to fall off.
Holy cow.
Yeah, platonically of course.
Platonically, you guys.
Anyway, this is so fun.
Thanks for all the tips helping me out with some of the items and helping me out when I had questions.
I really always appreciate that when you guys help me.
And this is a lot of fun.
Congrats on getting top four in the leaderboards.
First, I made it in...
Me and Doki had that...
Had that hotel sick and tired.
We had that 666 run on speed runs.
We had that speed run.
That made what?
Like top two.
Right?
And now...
Now this.
You guys, I'm on my way to the top, baby.
I'm on my way to the top.
We're killing it.
Yeah.
Top three.
Thanks for the streams.
Take care.
I hope you guys have a great day or have a great night, whatever time it is for you.
And, you know, I'm sorry again that the times have been a little...
I'm sorry.
Especially for my normal times.
So if you stayed up, thank you so much.
I'm so sorry.
Please get some sleep.
And yeah.
Have a great night.
Have a great day.
And I will see you guys not tomorrow because I will be at an event for the next two days.
I think I'm good.
I think the typhoon...
Hopefully the typhoon doesn't ruin my plans.
Let's go!
Our tori too thank you guys.
Bye bye.
See you.
I go.
Bye bye.
Oh my God.
You guys Maserata tell you.
So when I saw Mataro yesterday, she gave me a kinder egg, and I'm only...
I've never had a kinder egg that had the little toy inside.
And I got the toy inside.
But I got nothing.
And I was eating the egg and I was like, oh yeah, let me open up my toy and I opened it.
You guys, it was a lizard!
I hear him.
His tail shakes!
I was so... I opened it up and I audibly went... I was like...
It was right before stream.
I audibly went like, no way!
Yay!
He's so cute.
He's been my little buddy on my desk ever since I got him like five minutes ago.
Okay, bye-bye.